oh my name's Charlie McDowell welcome to
the first episode of how to be English
extreme so I'm pretty sure I asked my
sister's make me a cup of tea about half
an hour ago righty
still waiting on that cup of tea yeah oh
yeah sure you did
go tea yeah and now you get to see the
reason as to why I needed this cup of
tea ready so last year I showed you how
to make a simple humble cup of tea but
in this week's show although we will be
making tea we will be using tea making
techniques passed down by the tea gods
themselves this is pretty hardcore stuff
but if you think you're ready to become
a tea master then listen closely to my
words of wisdom you careful
Katie pot a mug some milk a teaspoon
some tea leaves some sugar and least but
not last a tea strainer okay I don't
know what that is firstly boil some
water in the kettle pour the water into
the teapot to warm up the teapot and
then pour the water out of the teapots I
don't really understand this step if I'm
perfectly honest but my mom says that if
you're going to make proper tea this is
the only way that you can start off by
warming up the teapot a little bit don't
ask me just do it who wants a cup of tea
you want to have 1 teaspoon of tea
leaves per person and then 1/4 the pots
pour in some boiling water and leave it
to brew for about 2 or 3 minutes
depending on how strong you want your
key to be if you want some sugar make
sure you add it at this point place your
tea strainer on top of your mug pour the
tea through the tea strainer to catch
all of the tea leaves add some milk to
taste stir and then you will have what
is without a doubt the perfect cup of
tea
I've been Charlie McDonnell and if
you're more of a coffee person then you
can go down a hole